S
HAVE BEEN UNDER FIRE FOR THE
QUTIONABLE STOCK TRADING.
LAST SUMMER PAUL PELOSI PLACED A
BED OF UP TO6 MILLION ON BIG
TECH GIANTSHEAD OF THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE MOVING FORWARDITH AN
TITRUST BILL AIMED ASILICA
ANTITANS.
OF IS THE LATEST B BAD NEWSFOR E
PAUL PELOSI CHAED WITH A DUI
IN NAPA AFTER A CAR CRASH.
SPEAKER PELOSI CONTINUES T SEE
HER PARTY INUCH DISARRAYS
EVER AS DEMOCRATS NOW FACEDMAJON
NOVEMBERRE LIKELY PUTTIN HER
OUT OF POWER.
HERE WITH REACTION, MBE THE
BEST BOOK HE'S EVER WRITN AND
AT'S "DEFEATING BIG GERNMENT
CIALISM."
HOW  PROTECT THE COURY,
FOX WS CONTRIBUTOR
NEWT GINICH.
TOMORROW NIGHT,HERE IS A LIVE
SIGNG OF HIS BOO 5:00 P.M.
EASTERN ON HIS FACEBOOK PAGE.LEE
EXACTLY.
THR ANSWER IS THE SPEAKERDOESN'T
THE TRANSACTIONS AREOR THE
SPOUSE AND SHE HAD NO KNOWLEDGE
OF THE INVOLVENT.
THENHEY SAY YOU SHOULD CHECK
WITH THEOMMITTEE ON THE
LATEST.
WHY IS THAT NOAN ADEQUATE'SRESPR
INFORMATION THAT CAUD HIM TO
INVEST IN THE SCKS?
THATOULD BE, AT LEAST WHERE
GREW UP, THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
LIKE INSIDER TRADING.
>> I WANT TO PROBAB SURPRISE
YOU A LITTLEIT HERE, SEAN.
THERE IS AN ENORMOUS DIERENCE
BETWEEN PAUL PELI AND HUNTERBID.
UL PELOSI IS A VERY
SOPHISTITED BUSINESS MAN WHS
BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME, BEEN
INVESTG FOR 50 YEARS.
HE READS
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THEFT
PEOP.
THE BET HE MADE WAS HIS MINORBA.
TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE,THER
ADVANTAGE OR IN A PARTILAR
COMPANY THAT'S PARTICULARLY AT
ADVANTAGE.
THAT WOULD BE INSIDER TRADING
AND THAT'S CLEARLY A FELONY AND
PELE WILL GO TO JAIL FOR IT.
BUT I SUSPECT IT'S COMMON
KNOWLEDG.
FOR MONTHS NOW, THE HOUSE IN THE
SENATE DEMOCRA ARE SLUGGING
THEIR WAY THROUGH ON A PRETTY
BIPARTISAN BIS TRYING TO GET
THE CH BILLED THROUGH TO
COMPETE WITH CHINA.
THE DIFFENCE BETWEEN PAUL
PELOSI IS THAT HE'S A SERIOUS
FINANCIAL GUY.
WHAT WE SEE WITH HTER BIDEN IS
PURE CORRUPTN.
IT'S ERMOUS AND IF I WERE
FOCUSN BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM, WOULD START WITH
THE PRESIDENTELEASING THE
AMERICAN OIL RESERVE ANDAVING
A MILLION BARRELS GO TO A
CHESE COMPANY WITH A
RELATIONSHIP WITH E
PRESIDENT'S SON
THAT TO ME I A CAR OPEN ANDSHUTY
IMPEACHABLE OFFEE.
I'M NOT PARTICULARLY DEFEING
PAUL ALTHOUGHE'S A VER SMART
BUSINESSMAN, BUT WHEN I READ THE
STORY, I DON'T AUTOMATICALLY ATR
TRING OR AN INSIDER DEAL.
>> Sean: IF THE LAST NAME WAS
TRUMP, I THINK WE'DE HAVING A
VERY DIFFERENT NARRATI IN THE
UNTRY.
JUST MY LITTLE TAPE.
THINK WE BOTH AGREE THAT
REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE BA THE
HOUSE.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
SLAM-DUNK.
BUT WHEN YOU OK AT FOR
EXAME, REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
HOLD NORTH CARINA,
PENNSYLVIA, WISCONSIN, THEY'
GOT TO HOLD OHIO.
THOSE ARE ALL BELETHERTATES
AND MISSOUR
THAT'S ATHER ONE.
THEN YOU LOOK FOR PICKUPS IN
GEORGIA WHICH JUST HAD
INTERPARTY TURMOIL SOMEWHAT, B
THEY'VE BE GOING AFTER HIMWITH E
WE MIGHT PUT STATES LIKE
W HAMPSHIRE, COLORAD
WASHINGTON STATE INLAY BUT
'VE GOT NEVADA, ARIZONA.THEN WVR
ATES POTENTIALLY TO DO WELL
IN.
ON PER, REPUBLICANS SHOULD W
BASED ON THE ECONOMY BUT I'MOT
BUYING INTO THATHIS IS GOING
TO BE A CAKEWALK.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK IT DEPENDS ENTIRELY
ONHE REPUBLICANS.
IF REPUBLICANS G BIG, THEY WILL
CRUSH THE DEMOCTS.
GEORGE IS GAT EXAMPLE.
IF REPUBLICANS G SMALL AND LEA
IT DEGENATE INTO A FIGHT
BETWN HERSCHEL WALKER A A
PERSON AND AY WARNOCK AS A
PERS, THEN I THINK IT'S AN UP
THE AIR KD OF RACE.
IF A PROFESSIONAL PREACHER, VERT
OF MEY.
BIDEN, NONPERCENTAGE INFLATION,
DOUBLI OF THE GAS PCE, ALL
THE PEOPLE COMG ACROSS THE
BORDER, THE RISING CRIME RATES,
FLORIDA IS JT GOING TO DROWN.
YOU GO ACRS THE COUNTRY A I
CANASILY SEE A CIRCUMSTAE
WHERE  REPUBLICANSLAY IT
STUPID, THEYAN E UP PICKING
UP MAYBE O OR TWO STILLMAJORITY.
IF THEY PLAY IT SMART, IF ERY
SING RACE YOU DESCRIBED
BECOMES A CHOE BETWEEN THE
BIDEN CANDIDATE WHO  KILNG
AMERICAND THE REPUBLICAN
ALTERNATE, I THINK YOU CAN SEE
EM SWEEP EVERY STATE.
WHEN I WORKED WITH RONALD REAGAN
IN 1980, THE FIR CAPITAL STEPS
EVENT,E HAD THE FIRST
NTRACT, WE PICKED UP 14 SENATE
SEATS.
NOT BECAUSE THE CANDIDATES WERE
BRILLIANT.
WE WON FIV OF THEM BY THE
MBINED TOTAL OF 75,00VOTES.
WHY?
THEY HAD A WAVE COMING IN
AMERIC WAVE, NOT REPUBLICAN.
AN AMERICAN WAVE.IF WE GET THE S
FALL.
YOU WILL BE SHOCKED HOW BIG THE
REPUBLICAN MORITY IN THE
SENATE IS.
>> Sean: IF THERE'S ABODY
RUNNING FOR OFFICE LISTENING TO
YOU NOW THAT DOESN GET ON THE
PHONE AND CALL YOU ANDSK VERY
SPECIFICALLYHAT THEY SHOULD BE
DOING,HEY ARE A IDIOTS.
THAT'SY ADVICE FOR ALL OF THEM
TO CALL YOU.
I' GIVE OUT YR NUMBER, DO
YOU MIND?
2 -- YOU KNOW I HAVE IT
MEMORIZED.
>> JUST PLAY THE EPISODE.
I JUST LAID OUT WHAT THEY NEEDT.
GO BIG, MAKET A BIG ELECTN
ABOUT BIG ISSUES.
>> Sean: YOUR BOOK OUTNEST
IN ITS VER TIMELY.
THAT'S THE BESTDVICE, THE
SINGLE BEST ADVICE.
THE NEXT THI THEY NEED TO DO
THE WAY, THEY NEED TO MEETT
AND DO IT WHETHEY GETLECTED.
AT'S A BIG PT OF THE
EQUAON TOO.
>> SHOULD BE A CONTRT OF THIS SE
KIND AND FALL.
>> Sean: T SENATE NEE TO
DO IT AS WELL.
>> McCONNELL SULD DO IT IN
THE SATE.
>> Sea